GOOD MORNING. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE WILL
COME TO ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING HEARINGS
HERE IN THE STATE CAPITOL. I ASK
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING, WE HAVE TEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA, AND WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE UNTIL WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AND WITH
THAT, WE WILL BEGIN WITH BILL
PRESENTATIONS. WE HAVE AN AUTHOR
HERE READY TO GO ASSEMBLY. SO
FILE ITEM ONE, AB 660 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN, IS ON THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY. AND COME ON UP
AND FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU
ARE READY.
WELL, GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 660
TODAY. FOR TOO LONG,
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN MISLED BY
UNCLEAR LABELS ON FOOD. STORE
STORES OFFER PRODUCTS WITH ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT LABELS, LIKE
EXPIRES ON BEST BEFORE. ENJOY.
BUY SELL, BUY, JUST TO NAME A
FEW. THESE LABELS CONSISTENTLY
MISLEAD AND CONFUSE CONSUMERS.
SELL BY DATES, FOR EXAMPLE, ARE
MEANT TO SHOW GROCERS WHEN THEY
WHEN TO ROTATE STOCK. THEY ARE
GENERALLY MEANINGLESS TO THE
CONSUMER. THE RESULT OF THIS
FOOD, CONSUMER CONFUSION IS
STAGGERING. IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
20% OF ALL FOOD WASTE IS CAUSED
BY CONSUMER CONFUSION, AND THIS
ULTIMATELY COSTS CONSUMERS MONEY
AT THE GROCERY STORE AND
CONTRIBUTES TO CLIMATE CHANGE AS
WASTED FOOD ROTS IN LANDFILLS.
AB 660 WOULD END THIS CONFUSION.
IT REQUIRES THE INDUSTRY'S OWN
ADOPTED STANDARDS AND REQUIRES
FOOD ITEMS THAT USE DATE LABELS
TO USE STANDARD TERMS BEST IF
USED BY TO INDICATE PEAK
FRESHNESS OR USE BY TO INDICATE
SAFETY. I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY CONTINUED APPRECIATION TO THE
INDUSTRY FOR ENGAGING IN
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR OFFICE TO FIND A PATH
FORWARD ON THIS BILL,
ESPECIALLY. WANT TO THANK, LOUIS
BROWN AND KATIE DAVEY FOR REALLY
MOVING THINGS FORWARD, THIS
YEAR, THE RECENT AMENDMENTS FOR
OUR BILL WERE CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED OVER THE COURSE OF
LAST YEAR. AND AS A RESULT, A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION. THESE INCLUDE THE
DAIRY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA,
THE CONSUMER BRANDS ASSOCIATION,
THE CALIFORNIA GROCERS
ASSOCIATION, AND THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, ARE ANDREA COLLINS,
REPRESENTING THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL, AND
ERIKA PARKER, REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S AGAINST WASTE.
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANDREA
COLLINS WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. AND
WE SUPPORT AB 660 BECAUSE IT
ADDRESSES A SYSTEMIC CAUSE OF
FOOD WASTE, WITH IMPLICATIONS
FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT, OUR HEALTH
AND OUR ECONOMY. TOO MANY OF US
LOOK AT A CONTAINER IN THE
FRIDGE OR OUR PANTRY AND SEE
THAT THE DATE HAS PASSED AND
DECIDE TO TOSS IT RATHER THAN
GETTING SICK. AND SOME OF THOSE
ARE ACTUALLY SELL BY DATES.
THEY'RE MEANT TO HELP GROCERY
STORES STOCK ROTATION, THÀNH AND
MANY OTHERS ARE INTENDED TO RELY
PEAK QUALITY OR FRESHNESS, BUT
YOU CAN'T TELL THAT JUST BY THE
PHRASE ON THE PACKAGE. INSTEAD,
WE'RE LEFT TO GUESS AT WHAT IT'S
MEANT. AND MORE THAN 80% OF
AMERICANS TOSS FOOD JUST BECAUSE
IT'S PAST DATE. REFIT IS A DATA
ANALYSIS GROUP THAT
CONSERVATIVELY ESTIMATES 600,000
TONS OF FOOD ARE WASTED IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR, JUST
BECAUSE OF THE DATE ON THE
PACKAGE, AND STANDARDIZING DATE
LABELS WOULD HAVE A FINANCIAL
BENEFIT OF $350 MILLION. MOST OF
THAT WOULD GO TO CALIFORNIANS IN
THEIR HOUSEHOLDS, BUT SOME WOULD
ALSO GO TO MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS AS WELL. KROGER AND
WALMART HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
THE STANDARDS ON THEIR HOUSE
BRANDS, BUT THAT'S A SMALL
NUMBER OF ITEMS THAT ARE ON THE
SHELVES ALREADY. WE NEED
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ALL FOOD
ITEMS AND WE HAVE ENOUGH FOOD.
BUT 8 MILLION CALIFORNIANS FACE
FOOD INSECURITY, AND THESE FOOD
PACKAGE DATES ARE A CHALLENGE TO
FOOD BANKS AND PANTRIES THAT
HELP SENIORS AND FAMILIES IN
NEED OF FOOD ASSISTANCE TO HAVE
ENOUGH FOOD TO EAT. BUT PANTRY
RECIPIENTS MAY BE RELUCTANT TO
TAKE FOOD THAT'S NEAR OR PAST A
DATE BECAUSE THEY'RE UNSURE
WHETHER IT'S SAFE FOR THEM OR
THEIR FAMILIES. EVEN IF THAT'S
NOT THE CASE, WE NEED CONSISTENT
DATE LABELS SO THAT PEOPLE STOP
TOSSING GOOD FOOD PREMATURELY
WHEN IT COULD HAVE BEEN
NOURISHING US. INSTEAD FOR THESE
REASONS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
ERIKA PARKER WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE. A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF AB 660
CALIFORNIANS THROW AWAY NEARLY 6
MILLION TONS OF FOOD WASTE EACH
YEAR, AND CONSUMER CONFUSION
OVER DATE LABELS IS A LEADING
CAUSE. THERE ARE MORE THAN 50
DIFFERENTLY PHRASED DATE LABELS
IN THE US. EACH TERM CAN BE USED
TO COMMUNICATE DIFFERENT THINGS
WHEN USED BY DIFFERENT BRANDS.
WHILE SOME DATE LABELS COMPLAIN
OR CONTAIN NO EXPLANATION AT
ALL, I'M SURE WE'VE ALL FOUND
OURSELVES CONFUSED BY ONE OF
THESE LABELS. JUST THE OTHER
DAY, I WAS SCRATCHING MY OWN
HEAD, CONFUSED AT PEB. NEXT TO A
DATE ON A BAG OF TORTILLAS DATED
FOR FEBRUARY. THE LACK OF
CONSISTENT AND CLEAR LABELING
RESULTS IN CONSUMER CONFUSION
AND SUBSEQUENT PREMATURE FOOD
WASTE OF WHOLESOME AND
NUTRITIOUS FOOD. IN FACT, ABOUT
20% OF AVOIDABLE FOOD WASTE CAN
BE ATTRIBUTED TO DATE LABELING.
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, PEB
MEANS PLEASE ENJOY BY. IT'S
POLITE, BUT STILL UNCLEAR. IN
2017, THE INDUSTRY'S TWO LARGEST
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS ATTEMPTED TO
ALLEVIATE THIS CONFUSION,
ANNOUNCING THAT THEY WOULD
IMPLEMENT UNIFORM DATE LABELING
USING BEST OF USE BY AND USE BY.
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT WAS FOLLOWED
BY A REPORT ENTITLED BEST IF
CLEARLY LABELED, WHICH FOUND
AMERICANS COULD FEEL SAFER ABOUT
THEIR FOOD, THROW LESS AWAY AND
SAVE MONEY WITH THESE LABELS,
THEY PROMISE LARGE SCALE
ADOPTION AND COMMITTED 100%
IMPLEMENTATION BY 2020. THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO CODIFIED THE
INDUSTRY'S PROPOSED TERMINOLOGY
AS A VOLUNTARY STANDARD IN AB
954. IN 2024, INCONSISTENCY IN
DATE LABELING CONTINUES TO
CONFUSE AND DATE LABEL RELATED
FOOD WASTE REMAINS AN ONGOING
CONCERN. AB 660 SIMPLY REQUIRES
BRANDS TO USE CURRENT VOLUNTARY
STANDARDS, WHICH ARE THE SAME
TERMS THAT THEY THEMSELVES HAVE
IDENTIFIED TO REDUCE CONSUMER
CONFUSION. THE FOOD CYCLE
DOESN'T END AT THE TRASH CAN,
AND FOOD WASTE COMES WITH A
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL AND
SOCIAL PRICE. AB 660 BUILDS ON
EXISTING EFFORTS TO PROTECT
NATURAL RESOURCES AND REDUCE
FOOD WASTE GOING TO LANDFILLS,
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. I'M GOING TO BRIEFLY
INTERRUPT INTERJECT HERE TO SEE
IF WE CAN JUST ESTABLISH QUORUM.
SO ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR SORRY.
SENATORS HURTADO PRESENT HURTADO
PRESENT. GROVE. GROVE HERE.
ALVARADO. GIL. CORTEZ. PADILLA
PADILLA. PRESENT QUORUM. QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. OKAY, SO MOVING ON. DO
WE HAVE ANY INDIVIDUALS HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 660, PLEASE COME
ON UP. STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. HELLO. MY NAME IS
LARA DIÆN. I'M THE STATE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AND ALSO WANTED TO ADD ON
CALPERS STRONG SUPPORT. THE
PUBLIC INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
SAVANNAH JORGENSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE LUTHERAN OFFICE OF PUBLIC
POLICY, CALIFORNIA, IN STRONG
SUPPORT. HI, I'M JULIE ARNS, AND
I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD RECOVERY
COALITION. IT IS OUR MISSION TO
UNITE, EMPOWER AND ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD RECOVERY
ORGANIZATIONS TO ALLEVIATE FOOD
INSECURITY, REDUCE WASTE, AND
CHAMPION SUSTAINABILITY. WE ARE
IN FULL SUPPORT. CASTLE HERE ON
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND
THE CITY OF AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT. HELLO, MY
NAME IS JALEN JOYCE. ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK, WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS EMILY
BLACK. I'M HERE FROM REPLANT. WE
ARE A FOOD RESCUE ORGANIZATION.
WE'RE HERE TO SHOW OUR FULL
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, LOUIE BROWN, HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
DAIRIES INCORPORATED AND
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION,
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
AND WE'VE OFFICIALLY REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, DENNIS ALBION.
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER BRANDS
ASSOCIATION, WE ARE ACTUALLY THE
ONES WHO CREATED THE INITIAL
LANGUAGE AND DID, STUDIES
NATIONWIDE. SEE WHAT IS THE
CORRECT LANGUAGE HERE. AND SO
AFTER WORKING THROUGH IT WITH
THE AUTHOR, WE'VE REMOVED OUR
OPPOSITION AS WELL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. KATIE
DAVIS WITH THE DAIRY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE HERE TO
EXPRESS OUR THANKS TO THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US TO ADDRESS OUR MEMBERS
CONCERNS REGARDING THIS BILL,
AND WE'RE PLEASED TO BE REMOVING
OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS. CHRIS
REARDON, CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR, YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR LANGUAGE. AND WE ALSO
HAVE REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY,
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL,
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN SUPPORT,
WE'LL MOVE TO ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO IS LOOKING TO BE LEAD
OPPOSITION. SO SEEING NONE,
ANYONE HERE, WANTS TO COME UP
AND STATE THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE. OKAY
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
. OKAY. AND WE HAVE A COMMENT
FROM SENATOR GROVE. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. I REPRESENT A LOT OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS IN THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY AND THE AG INDUSTRY.
OBVIOUSLY, THE TOP THREE FOOD
PRODUCING COUNTIES IN THE WORLD
THAT PRODUCE FOOD, AND I
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THEM
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
THEY HAVE. I HAVE THE LARGEST AG
PRODUCER IN MY DISTRICT, OR ONE
OF THE LARGEST, IF NOT THE
LARGEST. AND, SO I APPRECIATE
YOU WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO MAKE SURE THAT, THEIR
CONCERNS WERE ADDRESSED BECAUSE
IT THE WITNESSES THAT CAME UP IN
SUPPORT TALKED ABOUT FOOD
SECURITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
THERE WAS A FOOD DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM, YOU KNOW, LIKE FOOD
SECURITY AND LESS FOOD WASTE.
AND, THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF
FOOD WASTE IF THESE DATES WERE
SET IN STONE, AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT FROM THE GROCERS THAT I
TALKED TO AND SPECIFICALLY THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT I REPRESENT IN
MY DISTRICT. SO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN IRWIN, I JUST WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL. WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE PROVIDE ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT WE COULD TO GET IT,
TO GET IT RIGHT AND, GET IT
GOING BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT.
IT'S ABOUT FOOD SECURITY. IT'S
ABOUT FOOD WASTE. IT'S ABOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND IT'S ALSO,
HOPEFULLY TO SAVE MONEY FOR,
MANY CALIFORNIANS. SO THANK YOU
FOR WORKING WITH US. AND WITH
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION. AND SO
ASSISTANT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
TIME IN COMING. I THINK IF WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS WELL FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS POLICY WAS INTRODUCED BACK
IN 2017. SO I SO IT TOOK A LOT
OF PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER. I DO
WANT TO THANK YOUR THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF, OUR GREAT
SUPPORTERS WHO WERE WILLING TO
TRAVEL ALL OVER THE STATE TO, TO
PREACH THE WORD. I'VE HAD GREAT
STAFF WORK HERE, BUT ESPECIALLY
THE OPPOSITION WHO WAS WILLING
TO CONTINUE TO COME TO US AND
TRY TO HAMMER OUT A SOLUTION AND
SO I FEEL WE'RE IN A REALLY GOOD
PLACE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU,
ASSISTANT C¯, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AB 660, FILE ITEM ONE AB
660 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS HURTADO
. HURTADO. AYE. GROVE GROVE.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. CORTEZ
PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE. THREE
ZERO. OKAY. SO, THE BILL HAS
THREE VOTES, BUT WE'LL PLACE
THIS BILL ON CALL TO ALLOW OTHER
MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, SENATORS.
OKAY. MOVING ON. WE HAVE, WE ARE
. 2313 ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT'S
IN THE ROOM, SO WE'LL MOVE ON
OVER TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. AND
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, AB
2313 WILL CREATE A REGIONAL
HEAVY EQUIPMENT SHARING PROGRAM
FOR FARMERS. YOU KNOW, AFTER THE
PURCHASE OF LAND, THIS EXPENSIVE
FARM EQUIPMENT IS A SECOND MOST
SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL INVESTMENT
THAT FARMERS HAVE TO MAKE, AND
THESE EQUIPMENT SHARING PROGRAMS
ALLOW PARTICULARLY SMALL FARMERS
TO BORROW EQUIPMENT THAT THEY
PERHAPS ONLY USE FOR A FEW DAYS
A YEAR, FROM REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND IF WE CAN BRING DOWN THAT
EQUIPMENT COST, WE CAN REALLY
HELP, SMALL FARMERS IN
PARTICULAR, SURVIVE. AND WITH ME
TODAY IS ANNE LARSON FROM
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURAL NETWORK AND JAMIE
FORNOS FROM COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS, AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT THEY HAVE TO
SAY. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. GOOD
MORNING. I'M ANNA LARSON,
ASSOCIATE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH
CAL KHN, THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK, AND
WE'RE A COALITION OF EIGHT
SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC FARMING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ADVOCATE FOR
POLICIES TO HELP FARMERS BE MORE
RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
SO, WHILE CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
COUNTRY IN AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION, WE'RE LOSING FAMILY
FARMS AND THE NUMBER OF FARMS
DECREASES WITH EACH AGRICULTURAL
CENSUS DUE TO MARKET PRESSURES
AND CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS. WITH
THE LATEST CENSUS SHOWING A 10%
10% DECREASE FROM 2017. SINCE
THIS, AND SO MORE THAN EVER,
FARMERS NEED SUPPORT TO HAVE
VIABLE AND RESILIENT
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS AND TO
HELP MEET STATE GOALS AND
TARGETS FOR AGRICULTURE. AND SO
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
MENTIONED, AFTER LAND, EQUIPMENT
IS OFTEN THE HIGHEST CAPITAL
EXPENSE FOR FARMERS AND CAN BE
OUT OF REACH. AND SO INVESTMENTS
IN SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT FOR
HEALTHY SOILS PRACTICES OR
WILDFIRE MITIGATION STRATEGIES
SUCH AS NO TILL DRILLS, WOOD
CHIPPERS, AND COMPOST SPREADERS
ARE OFTEN OUT OF REACH,
PARTICULARLY FOR SMALL AND MID
SCALE FARMERS. SO THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM AT CDFA
TO FUND FARMERS RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS,
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND OTHERS
TO START OR EXPAND EQUIPMENT
SHARING PROGRAMS. WE ALREADY
KNOW THIS WORKS BECAUSE THERE'S
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE THAT
HAVE STARTED THIS, BUT THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO MEET THE CURRENT
DEMAND AND SCALE OR START TO
MEET THE DEMAND FOR NEW
EQUIPMENT SHARING PROGRAMS. AND
SO, THIS BILL WOULD HELP THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS MEET THAT AND BE
ABLE TO HELP FARMS SUPPORT THEIR
FARMER VIABILITY AND RESILIENCE
AND SUPPORT SHARING, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT. AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. JAMIE FANOUS, POLICY
DIRECTOR, ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS OR CAF, WE REPRESENT,
AROUND 8000 SMALL AND MID SCALE
FARMERS ACROSS THE STATE.
CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE YOU'VE HEARD
ME SAY THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE,
WE ARE LOSING ROUGHLY 1500 SMALL
FARMS A YEAR, THE CHALLENGES
FACING SMALL SCALE FARMERS AND
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE
SIMPLE ACT OF GROWING FOOD, NOT
ONLY THAT, BUT THEIR MARGINS ARE
RAZOR THIN. AND INVESTING IN
EQUIPMENT LIKE A COMPOST
SPREADER OR A SEED DRILL IS JUST
OUT OF REACH, AB 2313 AS AS HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED, IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE EQUIPMENT
COSTS BUT ALSO INCREASE THE
CAPACITY FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DEVELOP FARMER
COOPERATIVES, AND FIND WAYS TO
ACTUALLY JUST INCREASE THE
CAPACITY OF SMALL SCALE FARMERS.
I THINK THEY'VE SHARED ENOUGH, I
HOPE THAT YOU CAN SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE HERE IN ROOM 112. PLEASE
COME UP. NAME, ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. ABBY ALVAREZ WITH THE
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK IN
SUPPORT. PURCELL. KUDOS HERE ON
BEHALF OF STOP WASTE AND
SUPPORT. JALEN JOYCE, ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA, CALIFORNIA FOOD
AND FARMING NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
ADDISON PETERSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED ORGANIC
FARMERS IN SUPPORT. MICHAEL.
JARED. ON BEHALF OF NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
, ERICA PARKER WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. REBECCA MARCUS, ON BEHALF
OF AMERICAN FARMLAND TRUST AND
SUPPORT. OKAY. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO ANY OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE IN THIS ROOM.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR GROVE, THANK YOU. I GET
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE POLICY COMES
OUT OF THIS BUILDING, REGARDLESS
IF IT'S THIS BILL OR OTHER BILLS
THAT CREATE HIGH COSTS FOR
OPERATIONAL, WHETHER IT'S
FARMING, ENERGY PRODUCTION OR
HOUSING COSTS, THE BILLS AND
POLICY THAT COME OUT OF THIS
BUILDING INCREASE THOSE COSTS.
AND THEN WE SEE A GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS COME BACK AND WANT
THOSE COSTS SUBSIDIZED BY THE
STATE, IF WE ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSE AND STOP PASSING POLICY
THAT INCREASE THE COST, WE MIGHT
ALL BE IN A BETTER PLACE
FINANCIALLY FOR THE BUDGET. AND
WE WOULDN'T DRIVE BUSINESSES.
YOU SAID 1500 SMALL FAMILY
FARMS. THEY OPERATE ON A RAZOR
THIN MARGIN. WELL, WHAT'S THE
ROOT CAUSE OF THAT? YEAH, GO
RIGHT AHEAD. SURE YOU SAID IT.
WHAT'S THE ROOT CAUSE OF THEIR
RAZOR THIN MARGIN AND NOT BEING
ABLE TO SURVIVE? I THINK IT'S A
NUMBER OF THINGS. AND IT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF ELEMENTS TO IT.
BUT ULTIMATELY THE AVERAGE SMALL
SCALE FARMER ONLY BRINGS IN
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 20,000 AND
40,000 A YEAR. THAT'S OFTEN
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T FIND MARKETS
THAT PURCHASE THEIR PRODUCT AT
WHAT IT'S VALUED AT. YOU'RE A
SMALL OPERATION. YOU'RE YOU'RE
GROWING ANYWHERE BETWEEN 40 TO
100 DIFFERENT TYPES OF CROPS.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK TO MAINTAIN
THAT VERY DIVERSE ECOSYSTEM, SO
I WOULD SAY OFTENTIMES SOMETIMES
JUST PRICE, ALONG WITH A NUMBER
OF OTHER THINGS. BUT, THAT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE. YOU KNOW,
IT'S, IT'S COST. IT'S THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS. IT'S THE COST
TO PRODUCE THAT STUFF. IT'S THE
COST OF THE REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE. IT'S THE COST. AND
THEN THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT,
DEFENDING THOSE SMALL FARMERS AS
THEY GO THROUGH THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS. AND THEN WE IMPORT FOOD
FROM VENEZUELA THAT WE CAN GROW
HERE THAT IS GROWN WITH HUMAN
FECES. HUMAN FECES, EXPOSURE,
WATER, YOU KNOW, WASTEWATER
THAT'S NOT EVEN ADEQUATE. WE
WOULD NOT CONSIDER ADEQUATE FOR
HUMAN CONSUMPTION. BUT WE BRING
THAT FOOD HERE, AND SO I GUESS
MY THING IS, IS THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE IMPORT AND THIS IS JUST AN
EXAMPLE, AND I'M GOING TO GO ON
MY LITTLE TIRADE. WE IMPORT
ENERGY FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
AND THEN WE LAY OFF ALL OUR OIL
FIELD WORKERS, SECOND CHANCERS.
AND THEN WE SUBSIDIZE THEM AND
WE GIVE THEM FOOD STAMPS AND
SNAP BENEFITS AND OIL FIELD
WORKER RETRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
COST THE STATE RESOURCES. JUST
GIVE THEM THEIR JOB BACK. THESE
SMALL FARMERS ARE PLAYING
PERMITS, WATER MITIGATION FEES.
I MEAN, WATER IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS AN UNGODLY DOLLAR
AMOUNT FOR EVERY ACRE FOOT.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DRILL ON
YOUR OWN LAND ANYMORE. THAT'S A
SIGMA ISSUE YOU HAVE TO GET. YOU
HAVE TO PAY FEES AND PERMIT
THINGS TO SUBSIDIZE OR BE ABLE
TO FUND THE ENTIRE, STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. THAT IS
100% FARMER FUNDED, OR PEOPLE
THAT APPLY FOR PERMITS, IT'S
PERMIT FUNDED OR FEE FUNDED, I
GUESS YOU WOULD SAY, AND THEN WE
COME BACK AND WE SUBSIDIZE IT.
LET'S JUST GET TO THE ROOT CAUSE
AND STOP PASSING POLICY. AND
THEN WE WOULD ADDRESS OUR BUDGET
CRISIS, BECAUSE EVEN IN CHILD
CARE, WE INCREASE THE COST OF
CHILD CARE WITH POLICIES THAT GO
OUT OF THIS BUILDING. AND THEN
WE SUBSIDIZE CHILD CARE. WE
INCREASE THE COST OF FOOD AND WE
SUBSIDIZE FOOD, WE ARE ONE OF
THE MOST GREATEST INNOVATIVE
STATES IN THE WORLD, AND WE HAVE
THE GREATEST FARMLAND EVER
AVAILABLE. I MEAN, WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, PROBABLY BETTER
THAN IOWA. WE HAVE GREAT
FARMLAND. AND, BUT WE REGULATE
THE HECK OUT OF IT. AND THEN WE
IMPORT FOOD FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
. AND I JUST WISH WE WOULD TAKE
A STEP BACK AND SAY, THIS
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE ANYMORE, I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRINGING
FORWARD THE BILL BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE THAT PEOPLE NEED HELP
WITH IT, BUT THEY DON'T NEED
HELP FROM THE SUBSIDIZATION
PART. THEY NEED HELP FROM THE
REGULATORY RELIEF PART, SO THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME GO ON A RANT.
SORRY YEAH. THANK YOU. JUST
BRIEFLY. AND IT'S THE ONGOING
DEBATE ABOUT WHERE THE COSTS ARE
CALCULATED, WHERE THEY'RE
INCREMENTAL, AND WHAT WHAT ARE
THE PRIMARY FACTORS THAT DRIVE
ULTIMATE PRICING AND
SURVIVABILITY. I GET ALL THAT.
BUT, I THINK THE BILL IN CHIEF
HERE ACTUALLY, IRONICALLY, IN
SOME RESPECTS, ALLOWS A SMALL
FARMER WHO DOESN'T HAVE LEVERAGE
AND A LOT OF CAPITAL TO BE ABLE
TO LEVERAGE IN THE FINANCIAL
SENSE, THOSE RESOURCES IN A WAY
THAT MAXIMIZES BENEFIT THEY
OTHERWISE COULDN'T AFFORD,
UNDERSTAND THERE MAY BE SOME
INDIRECT SUBSIDY, BUT THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THOSE PURCHASES
TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE SEEMS TO
ME THERE'S SOME SAVINGS HERE FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL WHO UTILIZES THE
PROGRAM FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL, AND
WITH THE BILL. THANK YOU. I WILL
GO AHEAD AND ADD AND SAY THAT
I'VE, HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
EARLIER THIS YEAR, TO VISIT A
COUPLE OF FARMERS IN MY DISTRICT
, SMALL SCALE FARMERS. AND THIS
IS A MUCH NEEDED PROGRAM THAT
THEY BENEFIT FROM. AND WE NEED
TO FURTHER SUPPORT IT. AND SO
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT OF
COMMENTS, I THINK I'D BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS. AND I APPRECIATE THE
SENATOR'S CONCERNS ABOUT,
REGULATION AND THE DEBATE THAT
WE CAN HAVE ABOUT WHETHER WE'RE
OVERREGULATING, OR NOT. BUT I
WOULD OFFER THIS THAT EVEN IF WE
REMOVED VIRTUALLY ALL OF THE
REGULATION OUT THERE, THAT MAY
BE INCREASING COST FARMERS WHO
ARE HAVE GROSS REVENUES OF 20 TO
$40,000 WOULD STILL NEED HELP
WITH LARGE EQUIPMENT. IF WE HAVE
A DESIRE TO KEEP SMALL FARMERS
AS PART OF THE AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA, AND
I WOULD OFFER BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND A NUMBER OF
ASSOCIATED ISSUES WITH THAT, THE
RESILIENCY OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE IS PARTIALLY GOING
TO DEPEND UPON SMALL FARMERS
LOCATED NEAR LARGE URBAN CENTERS
THAT CAN PROVIDE THE FARMERS
MARKETS AND ALL OF THOSE ISSUES.
SO, REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE MIGHT
FALL ON THE REGULATORY QUESTION,
WE NEED TO SUPPORT SMALL FARMERS
, BECAUSE IF NOT IN A FEW YEARS,
THEY SIMPLY WILL NOT EXIST. AND
SO THE QUESTION IN FRONT OF US
TODAY IS NOT HOW DO WE DEAL
WITH, QUESTIONS OF HOW MUCH
REGULATION THAT'S NOT GOING TO
PROTECT THESE SMALL FARMERS OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS, REGARDLESS
OF THAT, WE HAVE TO FIND SOME
WAYS TO DEAL WITH THIS MOST
EXPENSIVE ISSUE, WHICH IS THIS
FARM EQUIPMENT. SO I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT, AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AND AT THIS MOMENT,
WE'LL HAVE THE ASSISTANT, DO THE
ROLL FILE ITEM SIX AB 2313 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT. MOTION
IS Dð PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR HURTADO I. HURTADO I
GROVE. ALVARADO. GIL. CORTEZ
PADILLA. PADILLA I. OKAY. WE
HAVE THE VOTE. THAT BILL HAS TWO
VOTES, AND WE'LL PLACE IT ON
CALL TO ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND WE DON'T I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE AN AUTHOR IN THE
ROOM. WE HAVE TWO BILLS LEFT,
BUT WE'LL WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP CONSENT BEFORE SENATOR
GROVE HEADS TO HER OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARING. SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSISTANT, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? OH, DIDN'T WE
THREE MEMBERS, WE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM WITH THE ROLL CALL. YEAH.
NICE YEAH. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR STEVE PADILLA TO MOVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, THE MOTION IS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR, FILE
ITEMS THREE, FOUR, EIGHT, NINE
AND TEN AB 1861, 21, 43, 26, OH
SIX, 27, 45 AND 2827 SENATORS
HURTADO A, HURTADO I, GROVE,
GROVE, I. ALVARADO, GIL, CORTEZ,
PADILLA, PADILLA, I SO LONG. ALL
THREE ON CALL OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ON CALL. THANK YOU.
GOT IT. GO ON. WE WILL, GO ON A
SHORT RECESS, PENDING. WE, GET
NEW AUTHORS IN THE ROOM, AND WE
HAVE ONE. SO ACTUALLY, NEVER
MIND. WITH A FLOURISH. GOOD
TIMING. OKAY MOVING ON. WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, AB 1042 BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAUER KAYHAN.
KAYHAN WRITE KAYHAN. BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT'S ENOUGH? FINALLY. SO
WE'RE GOOD. THANK YOU. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE, I WANT TO BEGIN
BY EXPRESSING MY DEEP GRATITUDE
TO COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
PARTNERSHIP ON GETTING THIS BILL
OUT DURING YEAR TWO, AND WORKING
WITH US ON THAT, HOPEFULLY IT
GETS OUT, CURRENTLY IN THE STATE
, TREATED SEED LABELS MUST
IDENTIFY THE TREATMENTS USED.
HOWEVER THEY DO NOT INCLUDE THE
CONCENTRATION AMOUNT OF EACH
TREATMENT WITH INCREASING LEVELS
ON SEED TREATMENTS, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF THESE PESTICIDES. THE
TREATMENT USED ON SEEDS ARE
OFTEN SYSTEMIC, MEANING THEY
STAY IN THE PLANTS THROUGH THEIR
LIFE CYCLE. RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT WHEN APPLIED DIRECTLY TO A
SEED, 95% OR MORE OF THE ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS TYPICALLY STAY IN
THE SOIL, CONTAMINATING OUR
WATER SUPPLY AND OUR FOOD
SOURCES. EXPOSURE FROM
PESTICIDES ON SEAS HAS BEEN
LINKED TO BEE POPULATION DECLINE
AND NEGATIVE HEALTH IMPACTS FOR
HUMANS, MAKING THE CONCENTRATION
INFORMATION OF SEED TREATMENTS
MORE TRANSPARENT. IT WILL MAKE
PROGRESS IN ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS IN WHAT
THEY USE. THIS BILL DOES NOT BAN
THE USE OF ANYTHING, IT MERELY
GIVES CONSUMERS THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS. AND I THINK THIS IS
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO ALSO
REITERATE THAT I AM NOT HERE TO
SAY THAT TREATED SEEDS ARE WORSE
THAN OTHER PESTICIDES, BUT I
THINK THAT ON OTHER PESTICIDES,
WE HAVE VERY CLEAR DISCLOSURES,
VERY CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING. AND SEEDS HAVE
BEEN THIS GAPING HOLE IN THAT
UNDERSTANDING. AND SO THIS WILL
ALLOW FOR A BROADER
UNDERSTANDING FOR FARMERS OR
OTHERS WHO USE THESE PESTICIDES
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS, WITH
THAT, I WILL TURN IT OVER TO Ó.
AND I'M ACCEPTING COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
SO I READ YOUR MIND, AND I ALSO
WANTED TO SAY THAT, AS I'VE HAD
A CONVERSATION WITH OTHERS, I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS WHO
YOU'LL HEAR FROM TODAY TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE AND
OTHER ISSUES THAT REMAIN ON, A
QUESTION OF THE BILL ARE WORKED
THROUGH AS WE MOVE FORWARD. AND
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT ARE
LARA DEHGHAN FROM ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA AND ANDREA COLLINS
WITH NRDC. HELLO. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
, MY NAME IS LARA DIÆN. I'M THE
DIRECTOR FOR ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA, AND WE'RE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WE'RE HAPPY TO
SPONSOR, AB 1042, AND WE THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
FARMERS AND THE PUBLIC THAT
THERE'S CLEAR TRANSPARENCY ON
THE CONCENTRATIONS OF THE
PESTICIDES ON THE SEED LABELS,
SO IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT FOR
SEEDS THAT ARE TREATED WITH
NEONICOTINOIDS OR NEONICS, WHICH
ARE LINKED TO PRETTY WIDESPREAD
IMPACTS ON POLLINATOR HEALTH,
LIKE OUR BEES, NOW, HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, 1 IN 3 NATIVE BEE
SPECIES ARE AT RISK OF
EXTINCTION. AND WE HAVE
INCREDIBLE BIODIVERSITY. THERE'S
1600 DIFFERENT SPECIES OF NATIVE
BEES. BUT THAT ALARMING, YOU
KNOW, STATISTIC IS REALLY
CONCERNING, ALSO, THERE'S BEEN
SERIOUS IMPACT WITH
NEONICOTINOID EXPOSURE ON BIRD
POPULATIONS, IN FACT, ONE SEED
THAT'S BEEN TREATED WITH, WITH
THESE PESTICIDES IS, IT COULD
HAVE ENOUGH OF THAT PESTICIDE TO
ACTUALLY KILL A SINGLE SONGBIRD,
WHEN IT, WHEN THE BIRDS EAT THE
SEEDS, IT CAN REALLY SUPPRESS
HER APPETITE. IT CAN AFFECT
REPRODUCTION AS WELL. IF IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY KILL THEM
DIRECTLY, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S CONCERNING.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN JUST OVER THE
LAST 25 YEARS, A GROWING
TOXICITY OF OUR FARMLAND BIRDS.
IN FACT, THERE WAS A RECENT
STUDY THAT FOUND THAT, FARMLANDS
ACROSS AMERICA ARE 25 OR SORRY,
ACTUALLY, 48 TIMES MORE TOXIC
THAN THEY WERE JUST 25 YEARS
AGO, TO INSECTS TO THE BIRDS AND
THE AND TO THE BEES AND THE
BUTTERFLIES AND OTHER WILDLIFE,
AND OF COURSE, ALL OF THAT
TOXICITY ALSO AFFECTS HUMAN
HEALTH. SO THAT'S ALL REASONS
WHY WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
EMPOWER FARMERS WITH AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS WE CAN, SO THEY
CAN MAKE RESPONSIBLE CHOICES TO
LIMIT THE IMPACTS ON NATURE AS
THEY'RE GROWING FOOD. AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. YEAH. SORRY. THANKS.
THANK YOU. CHAIR HURTADO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
ANDREA COLLINS WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL, AND
WE SUPPORT AB 1042, WHICH WILL
PROVIDE GREATER CLARITY TO
GROWERS REGARDING THE PESTICIDES
THAT ARE USED TO COAT THEIR
SEEDS. CURRENTLY LABELS FOR
TREATED SEEDS ARE REQUIRED TO
IDENTIFY WHICH PESTICIDES ARE
USED IN THE SEED TREATMENT, BUT
NOT THE AMOUNT AND AB 1042 WOULD
SIMPLY REQUIRE THAT THE AMOUNTS
BE LISTED AS WELL. IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE USE OF
SEED TREATMENTS IS WIDESPREAD
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA, BUT
INDIVIDUAL FARMERS HAVE LIMITED
INFO ABOUT HOW MUCH PESTICIDES
THEY'RE ACTUALLY USING IN
CALIFORNIA. GROWERS DESERVE
BETTER INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CHEMICALS THAT THEY THEY'RE
SPENDING THEIR HARD EARNED MONEY
ON AND PUTTING INTO THEIR SOIL
WITH ACCURATE, EASILY ACCESSIBLE
QUANTITY INFORMATION FOR SEED
TREATMENTS, FARMERS WILL BE ABLE
TO COMPARE PRODUCTS AND REDUCE
THE USE OF UNNECESSARY,
SOMETIMES HARMFUL AND OFTEN
COSTLY CHEMICAL INPUTS, AND THIS
INFORMATION IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT FOR SEEDS TREATED WITH
NEONICS. AS WAS MENTIONED
PREVIOUSLY, THEY'RE
EXCEPTIONALLY TOXIC TO INSECTS.
ONE TREATED CORN SEED HAS ENOUGH
ACTIVE INGREDIENT TO KILL A
QUARTER OF A MILLION BEES THAT
WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
HARMS TO POLLINATORS AND BIRDS,
BUT IT DOESN'T STOP THERE EITHER
. RESEARCH LINKS NEONICS TO
NEUROLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT AND
REPRODUCTIVE HARM, INCLUDING
BIRTH DEFECTS OF THE HEART AND
THE BRAIN, AND A RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT 95% OF PREGNANT WOMEN
HAD NEONICS IN THEIR BODIES.
IT'S ESPECIALLY HIGH IN LEVELS
OF HISPANIC WOMEN AND TREATS
TREATED SEEDS ALSO THREATENED
THE HEALTH OF FARM WORKERS AND
THOSE WHO COME INTO CONTACT WITH
HIGH CONCENTRATIONS OF
PESTICIDES WHEN THEY'RE EITHER
APPLYING THE SEED COATINGS OR
THEY'RE HANDLING TREATED SEEDS
IN THEIR DAY TO DAY JOBS. WITH
TRANSPARENCY OFFERED BY AB 1042,
IT WILL BE EASIER FOR FARMERS TO
TRACK THEIR NEEDS AND THEIR
COSTS AND THE ACTUAL VALUE THAT
THEY'RE RECEIVING FROM THESE
PRODUCTS, AS WELL AS TO TAKE THE
NECESSARY SAFETY PRECAUTIONS
WHEN HANDLING THEM. AB 1042 IS A
LIGHT LIFT THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND SO WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE. PLEASE COMMENT,
COME UP AND STATE YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING ABIGAIL SMITH, ON
BEHALF OF THE MIDPENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT ABBY ALVAREZ WITH THE
PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN SUPPORT. JUSTIN BOWERS
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS ORG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN ADDITION
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
FACTS ECOSYSTEM ABILITY PEEPS
THE NCCA, SONOMA SAS, SAFE AG
SAFE SCHOOLS, YARD SMART MARIN
BEYOND PESTICIDES, MOMS
ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY AND
NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES ALSO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL. JARED, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE FOR BIODIVERSITY, IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, REBECCA
MARCUS, ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR FOOD SAFETY AND CALPIRG IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT, IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE? IF
SO, PLEASE COME ON UP FRONT
HERE. GO ON. WANT TO MAKE SURE
THERE'S ROOM FOR YOU, DENNIS?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DENNIS
ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF, THE
CALIFORNIA SEED ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION, THE ALFALFA AND
FORAGE ASSOCIATION, SEVERAL
OTHER ENTITIES, SO, FIRST OF
ALL, WE APPRECIATE THE
ACTIVITIES FROM THE AUTHOR AND,
AND HAVE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
TREATED SEEDS DISCUSSIONS. THE
TREATED SEEDS ARE ALREADY
LABELED. SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED FROM THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY. AND WE HAVE WORKED
VERY CLOSELY. AND IT'S ALSO
THERE'S SOME SCIENTIFIC THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE. WE PUT IT IN OUR IN
OUR LETTERS AND CITED IT THAT
ACTUALLY WE'RE USING TREATED
SEEDS, GETTING THE SEED IN THE
PLANT OUT OF THE GROUND AND
GERMINATED IN A IN A EFFECTIVE
MANNER, ACTUALLY REDUCES THE
NEED FOR FOLIAR APPLICATIONS. IT
CAN REDUCE THE OVERALL AMOUNT OF
PESTICIDES NEEDED IN THE
ENVIRONMENT TO GROW A HEALTHY
CROP. SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S NEEDED TO BE
DOING THIS. WE USE TREATED SEEDS
BECAUSE IT HELPS BRING A HEALTHY
PLANT JUST LIKE WE DO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION TO BRING THE
STUDENTS ALONG. THE SAME THING
WITH PLANTS. SO TREATING SEEDS
HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO A LOT OF
ACTIVITY WITH LEGISLATION,
PETITIONS AT DPR AND THERE'S
ACTUALLY CURRENTLY A LAWSUIT,
THAT'S IN A COURT APPROVED
SETTLEMENT CONFERENCE THERE AT
DPR. SO WE WERE A LITTLE
SURPRISED. AND ON THIS BILL THAT
WHEN THE SENATE AG COMMITTEE
CALLED US AND SAID, HEY, WE'RE
YOU KNOW, ARE YOU AWARE THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING AT AMENDMENTS TO
IT? BECAUSE IT WAS QUITE A
CONTROVERSIAL LITTLE SUBJECT. SO
WE IMMEDIATELY GOT INVOLVED, GOT
OUR CONVENED LAST TUESDAY WHEN
WE SAW THE LANGUAGE AND WHEN IT
WAS PUT INTO PRINT, WE CONVENED
OUR EXPERTS AND SAID, WHAT'S THE
REGULATORY AREA OUT THERE?
WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON? WHAT'S
NECESSARY, WHAT'S NOT? WE
ACTUALLY EVEN REACHED OUT. WE
WERE THE FIRST ONES TO REACH OUT
TO CDFA AND GAVE THEM THE
LANGUAGE AND HAD THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH CDFA AS WELL.
SO WE PUT A LOT OF TIME IN THE
LAST ONE WEEK ON THIS ISSUE. AND
SO I THINK WE CAN AGREE THAT IF
YOU WANT TO DO THE CONCENTRATION
ON THE DEAL THAT WE HAVE AGREED
TO THAT, BUT IT'S MUCH MORE
COMPLEX THAN EVEN, YOU KNOW, A
SIMPLE ONE LINE IN A IN A BILL.
AND SO I THINK WE NEED TO DO
THAT. SO WE HAVE PROPOSED SOME
AREAS, FIRST OF ALL, THE AREA OF
LAW THAT THEY THAT THE BILL,
HAS, AMENDS ACTUALLY IS MUCH
MORE BROAD THAN JUST PESTICIDES.
IT COULD BE A FERTILIZER. THERE
COULD BE OTHER INGREDIENTS. IT'S
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, POISONS. AND
WHAT THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IS
TAKE THAT SEED, SAY IT'S CORN
SEED AND FEED IT TO CATTLE OR
FEED IT TO PEOPLE IF IT WAS
PUMPKIN SEEDS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. SO THAT'S WHAT THE
LABELING SECTION THAT THEY
SELECTED, DOES. SO WE NEED TO
NARROW IT DOWN IF WE'RE GOING TO
ADD REQUIREMENTS ABOUT
CONCENTRATION AND ACTIVE
INGREDIENTS IN THOSE AREAS, THEN
WE NEED TO NARROW DOWN AND FOCUS
IT ON PESTICIDES, BECAUSE THAT'S
REALLY WHERE THE CONCERN IS. AND
SO, SO WE'VE WE'VE PROPOSED THAT
TO GET IT FOCUSED ON THE
PESTICIDES. AND THE BEST WAY TO
DO THAT IS TO USE EITHER DPR
NUMBER OR THE US EPA NUMBER THAT
WAY WE KNOW WHAT IT IS. AND THEN
THE CONCENTRATIONS, DATES WE
HAVE PROPOSED, THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
SELL THROUGH REQUIREMENTS OR
STUFF THAT'S, THAT'S ON THE
SHELF OR WILL BE ON THE SHELF
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE YEAR
AND MAYBE NEXT YEAR, AS WE AS WE
GET THERE. SO WE NEED TO SELL
THROUGH DATE. WE THINK THAT ONE
127 FOR BOTH THE SELL THROUGH
DATE AND THE ENACTMENT DATE,
MAKES SENSE. GIVES TIME TO, TO
CHANGES OVER TO GET YOUR LABELS
APPROVED. ALL THOSE AREAS AGAIN
ANYTHING DEALING WITH THE
PESTICIDE LABEL HAS TO GO
THROUGH SEVERAL, REGULATION
TIERS OF REGULATION. SO WE THINK
THAT'S A FAIR DATE, AND AGAIN,
I'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THE
SELL THROUGH. AND THEN WE NEED
LABELING FOR TRANS SHIPMENT.
CALIFORNIA DOES, HAS A GREAT
SEED INDUSTRY, VERY PRODUCTIVE
SEED INDUSTRY. AND WE'RE OUR
DEMAND ALL OVER THE WORLD AS
WELL AS IN OTHER STATES. SO IF
WE'RE, WE'RE IF WE'RE DOING THIS
AND WE'RE PUTTING IT INTO A BAG
AND SHIPPING IT INTO ARIZONA,
MEXICO OR SOUTHEAST ASIA, THEN
THEY PROBABLY OUGHT TO HAVE
LABELS THAT MEET THOSE
REQUIREMENTS. AND I KNOW YOU
SAY, WELL, OF COURSE, THAT
WOULDN'T MEET. WELL, THE WAY THE
SECTION'S WRITTEN IS IT'S ANY
TRANSFER. AND SO THAT WOULD BE
TRANSFERRED COULD HAPPEN WITHIN
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEN IT, YOU
KNOW, GETS DRIVEN TO ARIZONA OR
MEXICO OR WHEREVER. SO DATA
LABELING NOT NECESSARILY TRANS
SHIPMENT OTHER THAN THAT I THINK
THERE'S A VERY MODEST REQUEST
FOR, FOR AMENDMENTS. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND WITH
THAT, WE LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
THE BILL TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
. IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
PLEASE COME STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION POSITION ON THE
BILL. HI. WE ARE GAIL DILLON
WITH WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
AND WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
DENNIS ALBIANI. AND WE ARE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED. GOOD
MORNING, TAYLOR. ON BEHALF OF A
VARIETY OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS, WE APPRECIATE THE
NARROWING OF THE BILL, BUT
REQUEST AMENDMENTS CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL ALSO
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED. CHRIS
REARDON, CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED.
JENNIFER ROWE, WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
BIOTECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
ORGANIZATION, ALSO OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. THANK
YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PAT
MORAN, WITH AARON REARDON
ASSOCIATES, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ASSOCIATE OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS, UAW. WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SORRY I WAS
LATE. THANK YOU. I WAS LIKE,
WAIT, WHAT HAPPENED? THANK YOU
FOR THE LAST, LAST, PERSON IN
SUPPORT. OKAY. BRINGING IT BACK
TO, COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS, SENATOR PADILLA,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, LOOK, THIS
IS A WORTHY BILL. AND RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS ON THE
INDUSTRIAL SIDE OF A DEEP
PERSONAL SENSITIVITY TO
ENVIRONMENTAL ELEMENTS THAT
IMPACT PUBLIC HEALTH IN WAYS
THAT WE'RE ONLY BEGINNING TO
UNDERSTAND. AND THE PRIMARY
DRIVER THERE IS GETTING IT
RIGHT. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
MAXIMUM DISCLOSURE. AND I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR, AT LEAST AT
THIS POINT, THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EXISTING STATE REGULATED
LABELING. SO IT'S A GOOD PLACE
TO START. THIS BILL DESERVES, IN
MY VIEW, TO GET OUT OF
COMMITTEE. AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
IT AT THE RIGHT TIME. SENATOR
ALVARADO, I'M HAVING THE SAME
ISSUE WITH THE BUTTON. YEAH HI,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REBECCA
BAUER-KAHAN, I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD,
UNFORTUNATELY, BECAUSE OF THE
KIND OF LIKE, THE, LATE
CONCERNS, I HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
TIME TO DIVE DEEP INTO IT, SO I
WANTED JUST TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION, THERE ARE SOME
TECHNICAL AREAS, RIGHT, THAT
THAT STILL NEED TO BE WORKED ON.
BUT OVERALL, THE INTENT I AGREE
WITH THE OVERALL INTENT. I'M
JUST WONDERING ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW WE CAN
HELP TO CONNECT THOSE, THE GAPS
RIGHT NOW BETWEEN THE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION, THANK YOU,
SENATOR, FOR THE QUESTION, AND
GOT MY NAME RIGHT, WHICH IS
IMPRESSIVE, SO, YES, AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER, WE HAVE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS OVER THE LAST
WEEK WITH THE OPPOSITION AND
CONTINUE TO BE, THE, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS WHERE I
THINK WE'RE JUST TRYING TO NAIL
DOWN THE FINAL PIECES, SUCH AS
THE SELL THROUGH DATE, THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, THINGS LIKE
THAT, THERE ARE THE OTHER
CONCERNS AROUND TRANSFERRING OUT
OF STATE. I'M CURRENTLY TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
INCONSISTENCIES WORK WITH OTHER
LABELING REQUIREMENTS, SO WE CAN
MAKE SURE TO GET THAT RIGHT. I
DON'T HAVE A FULL GRASP OF THAT
QUITE YET, BUT I'M IN
CONVERSATIONS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT. AND THEN I
THINK, AND I APOLOGIZE, THE
OPPOSITION, IF I FORGET
SOMETHING, BUT I THINK I'M
GETTING THEM ALL SO CORRECT. THE
FOURTH WAS THE SCOPE OF WHAT IS
LABELED AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY, WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO
GET BETTER UNDERSTANDING FROM
EXPERTS, FROM THE SCIENTISTS AND
OTHERS, WHETHER THEY'RE, YOU
KNOW, AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
DISCLOSURES. YOU KNOW, I DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND WHY IN THE
SETTING OF, LIKE, A FERTILIZER,
WE SHOULDN'T BE DISCLOSING THE
QUANTITIES. I THINK THAT THE
POINT WAS MADE BY MY SPONSORS
THAT YOU ALSO DON'T WANT TO BE
BUYING SOMETHING THAT HAS DE
MINIMIS TREATMENT THAT ISN'T
GOING TO DO WHAT YOU WANT IT TO
DO. SO THERE ARE CONSUMER
PROTECTION ELEMENTS OF THIS THAT
I THINK ARE ALSO CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT, AND SO AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED, I DON'T SEE THE
DOWNSIDE OF THOSE DISCLOSURES.
AND I SEE THE UPSIDE. SO TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND IF THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS IS TO CHANGE OR
NOT. SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE I'M
ON ALL THE POINTS. IF THAT'S
HELPFUL. YES, THAT'S THAT'S
HELPFUL. THESE BUTTONS, HELP ME
WITH THE SCIENCE. LIKE HOW DO
YOU GO ABOUT MEASURING THE
QUANTITY ON A SEED? I MEAN, HELP
ME WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SCIENCE. NOW, YOU'RE
CHALLENGING THE LAWYER. OKAY IT
DIDN'T BECOME A SCIENTIST FOR A
REASON, SENATOR, BUT, I KNOW
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY POSSIBLE. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF ONE OF MY EXPERTS HAS A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THEY
DO IT. OKAY, I'M NOT A SCIENTIST
ON THAT. THAT ITEM IN
PARTICULAR. BUT SEED, HANDLE
OTHERS SHOULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION ALREADY AVAILABLE.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY SHOULD
ALREADY HAVE WHEN THEY HAVE THE
PESTICIDE. SO IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S DIFFICULT TO ACQUIRE. AND
I WILL I WILL ADD TO THAT THAT,
AS YOU HEARD FROM, THE
OPPOSITION THERE, THEY ACTUALLY
ARE NOT, AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
OPPOSED TO THE IDEA OF LABELING
THAT IN CALIFORNIA. BUT FOR ALL
THE, THINGS HE MENTIONED, WHICH
MEANS I THINK THAT THEY'RE
CONCEDING THAT IT'S POSSIBLE TO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION UNLESS
I'M WRONG. DENNIS. NO, NO, I, I
THINK WE NEED BACK UP EVEN THAT
WE WANT TO SPEAK FOR YOU. THAT'S
MADAM CHAIR. SO I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT, WELL, A COUPLE
THINGS. THE CONCENTRATION ISSUE,
IT IS SOME ENTITIES PROVIDE IT,
SOME DON'T. BUT HOW YOU DO IT IS
YOU APPLY IT AND IT'S USUALLY
JUST THEY RUN ON A CONVEYOR BELT
AND YOU KNOW, YOU SPRAY ON OR
YOU COAT THEM, BUT IT DOES
BECOME AN ISSUE WHERE, WHEN POST
THEY DO, THEY DO TEST THESE
THINGS. SO HOW IS THERE A
LABELING ISSUE WHEN YOU RUN
INTO, IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE
PROCESS ON A CONVEYOR BELT. SO
SOME OF THEM MAY BE UNDER A
SEED, MAY BE UNDERNEATH ANOTHER
SEED. SO MAYBE NOT EVERY SEED
GETS COATED, BUT THERE'S AN
APPLICATION CONCENTRATION
AVERAGE FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM. ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS WE
BROUGHT FORWARD ON THURSDAY WHEN
WE BROUGHT FORWARD, YOU KNOW,
OUR CONCERNS, WAS, IS, WE NEED
TO HAVE REGULATORY AUTHORITY AT
THE CDFA SO THAT THEY CAN
FURTHER DEFINE THINGS LIKE HOW
DO YOU TEST WHAT RATIOS, THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS, AND THEN YOU
KNOW, WE WORK WITH CDFA. WE
DISCOVERED, THAT THEY HAVE BROAD
AUTHORITY OVER THIS CHAPTER TO
DO REGULATION. SO WE DIDN'T NEED
THAT. THAT WAS, YOU KNOW, ONE WE
FIRST SPOKE TO THE STAFF SAID,
HEY, YOU KNOW, YOU PROBABLY NEED
REGULATORY AUTHORITY FOR CDFA
DON'T NEED THAT. SO I THINK
WE'VE BEEN I DON'T EVEN WANT TO
THINK I THINK WE HAVE BEEN I'M
GOING TO USE THE TERM GRACIOUS
COMING TO THE TABLE IMMEDIATELY
IN A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME,
TRYING TO GET THESE VERY
TECHNICAL ISSUES WORKED OUT. WE
CONCEDE THAT IF THEY WANT THE
CONCENTRATION OF PESTICIDES PUT
ON THE BILL ON THE ON THING, AND
THAT IS WHAT IS ARTICULATED BY
THE AUTHOR'S STAFF. OR WE MET A
COUPLE TIMES, THEN, THEN WE
CONCEDE THAT THESE AMENDMENTS
JUST SAY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SECTION OF LAW, IT DOESN'T EVEN
HAVE AN ENACTMENT DATE, BECAUSE
IT'S AN OLD SECTION OF LAW. SO
THAT WOULD BE JANUARY 1ST. IF
YOU LOOK AT IT, HOW IT'S
WRITTEN, JANUARY 1ST, 2025, WE'D
HAVE TO MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS.
WELL, THE BILL, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN THE BILL WOULD BE ENACTED
BY NORMAL, PROCESS OF ENACTMENT.
WELL, HANG ON, THERE'S PRODUCT
IN THE WAREHOUSES. YOU'D HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THIS. THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
DO SOME REGS. JUST SOME, SOME
SIMPLE THINGS. AGAIN I'M NOT
OVERSTATING THAT. IT'S THAT IT'S
A CHALLENGE. Tð CHALLENGING, BUT
IT JUST TAKES TIME. IT TAKES,
EXPERTS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TEST THESE, HOW TO MAKE IT SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT IMPROPERLY
LABELING. IF NOT EVERY SEED IS
PROPERLY CODED. AND SO THOSE ARE
THE ISSUES THAT WE WANT TO
ADDRESS. FRANKLY I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR'S ENTHUSIASM ON ON
SOME OF THE THINGS, BUT I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE WOULDN'T TRY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN THIS IN
THIS COMMITTEE, THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMITTEE, THIS IS OUR
EXPERTISE. AND DO THIS, THERE'S
A COUPLE ISSUES THAT ARE BEING
BROUGHT UP IN THE IN, AND I
THINK THERE'S SOME AMENDMENTS
THE AUTHOR WANTED TO PROVIDE. IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN, AND THOSE ARE
EVEN AWKWARDLY DRAFTED. SO WE
JUST NEED SOME WORK TO DRAFT
THEM. HEY, WE'RE NOT SAYING HOLD
THE BILL, BUT WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS LET'S AMEND THE BILL. OR AT
LEAST CONCEPTUALLY, BEFORE IT
LEAVES THIS COMMITTEE, BECAUSE
THIS IS WHERE SOME EXPERTISE IS.
AND FRANKLY, I THINK IT'S
FAIRLY, BASIC, AMENDMENTS,
NOTHING TO CONTROVERSIAL, THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME, I'LL BE
HONEST WITH YOU, FROM THE AUTHOR
THAT I'VE HEARD THAT. OKAY. IT'S
OKAY. LET'S CONTINUE. LET'S LOOK
AT FERTILIZERS AND OTHER, MAYBE
EVEN INERTS THAT MIGHT HAVE THAT
MIGHT BE POISONOUS TO HUMANS OR
WHATEVER. AND, AND I THAT WOULD
PROBABLY CHANGE SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT IF BECAUSE NOW
WE GOT TO BRING IN THE
FERTILIZER GUYS GOT TO BRING IN
EVERYBODY. THIS IS I WOULD KEEP
IT DOWN TO PESTICIDES. THAT'S
WHERE THE CONTROVERSY HAS BEEN.
THAT'S WHERE ALL THOSE
ACTIVITIES ARE. THAT'S WHERE THE
LAWSUITS ARE. THAT'S WHERE
EVERYTHING IS. I WOULDN'T EXPAND
IT AT THIS POINT, AND, AND THINK
THAT WOULD BE A, NOT A
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION TO ENTER
INTO AT THIS TIME, IF I MAY,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD. JUST WANTED TO ADD, OF
COURSE, THAT, AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING, ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE
AND RESPECT THE EXPERTISE OF
THIS COMMITTEE. AND THEY
PROVIDED AND I HAVE EVERY
INTENTION OF ENSURING, AS IS
PRACTICE, THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
BE ENGAGED IN THE AMENDMENTS AS
WE MOVE THEM FORWARD. SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CLEAR. OKAY. GREAT. THANK YOU.
SO I YOU KNOW, I'M LOOKING QUITE
A BIT AT THE SUPPORT AND THE
OPPOSITION. I KNOW THAT THE BILL
HAS KIND OF EVOLVED OVER THE
LAST YEAR, I DO WANT TO HAVE,
SOME MORE TIME TO BE ABLE TO
KIND OF SEE THOSE THOSE GAPS BE
FILLED, I KIND OF CHUCKLED AT
THE ANALOGY BETWEEN THE CODING
OF THE SEED IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. SO YOU MADE MY
MORNING THERE, DENNIS. YOU GET A
HEALTHY START. YEAH BUT BUT ALSO
THE SCIENCE TO ME IS, IS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO UNDERSTAND
THE SCIENCE IF WE'RE DOING IT IN
OTHER, OTHER AREAS, OTHER
STATES, OTHER COUNTRIES, I WANT
TO SEE WHAT THAT IMPACT IS AS
WELL AS THE ECONOMIC IMPACT,
BECAUSE AGAIN, IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE SEED, WHICH IS THE
MOST, YOU KNOW, THE, THE, THE
ORIGIN OF OUR FOOD AND THE
ORIGIN OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY, I WANT TO ENSURE THAT,
YOU KNOW, THAT WE ARE NOT ADDING
AN ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC DRIVER
THAT CHANGES THE DIRECTION OF
FOOD AFFORDABILITY. SO THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALVARADO. GIL OKAY. WELL, I
MEAN, LAUGHTER IS A GOOD WAY TO
ASK IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. I
MEAN, I HAVE NO DOUBTS THAT YOU
GUYS ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AND, JUST ASK AT
THIS MOMENT IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND I WILL SAY THAT I KNOW THE
CHAIR, APPROPRIATELY, IS BEEN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
MANY OF THE SEEDS WE USE TODAY
ARE FOREIGN PRODUCED AND THAT
PART OF WHEN WE TALK ABOUT FOOD
SECURITY, WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PRODUCING THOSE THINGS
HERE AT HOME. AND SO THE LAST
THING I WANT TO DO IS HURT THAT
MARKET. BUT I THINK A LABEL
DOESN'T DO THAT. SO I THINK WE
CAN REALLY GET THERE. AND I
THINK THAT THERE THE POSTURE OF
THE OPPOSITION, I THINK, IS
ACCURATELY REFLECTIVE OF THAT.
AND THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
ABSOLUTELY STILL CONTINUE WITH
THE EXPERTISE OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND OTHERS. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. OKAY. WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PADILLA, AND I'LL GO
AHEAD AND ASK ASSISTANT TO, DO
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM TWO AB 1042
BY BAUER-KAHAN, THE MOTION IS DO
DO PASS TO AMEND, AS AMENDED, TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. SENATORS
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. GROVE
ALVARADO. GIL. NOT VOTING.
CORTEZ PADILLA. PADILLA. AYE
OKAY. WE'LL PLACE THAT THAT BILL
ON CALL. THANK YOU. OKAY. UP
NEXT, WE HAVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB 27344. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
WHEN YOU ARE READY. SIR.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING. AB 2734 SEEKS TO
UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
AND FOOD AND AGRICULTURE'S
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM BASED ON
FARMER INPUT. FARMERS HAVE
APPLIED TO HEALTHY SOILS, AND
I'LL CALL IT HSP FOR NEARLY A
DECADE TO IMPLEMENT CLIMATE
SMART CONSERVATION PRACTICES ON
THEIR FARMS. BASED ON THIS
EXPERIENCE, FARMERS RECOMMEND
SEVERAL UPDATES TO THE PROGRAM
WHILE HSPS HAVE MADE SUBSTANTIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO IMPLEMENTING
CLIMATE SMART CONSERVATION
PRACTICES ON FARMS, SEVERAL
PROGRAM CHANGES WOULD HELP
BETTER SUPPORT THE PARTICIPATION
OF PARTICULARLY SMALL SCALE AND
ORGANIC PRODUCERS. ORGANIC
FARMERS FEEL DISINCENTIVIZED AS
EARLY ADOPTERS OF CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES. BECAUSE HSP ONLY
FUNDS FARMERS TO IMPLEMENT NEW
PRACTICES, SMALL SCALE
PRODUCERS, IN PARTICULAR,
STRUGGLE WITH THE PAPERWORK
BURDEN AND COMPLICATED
APPLICATION PROCESS. YES, THESE
FARMERS WOULD ALSO BENEFIT FROM
MORE TOOLS LIKE AN EQUIPMENT
SHARING PROGRAM. FINALLY FARMERS
FACE FINANCIAL CHALLENGES WITH
THE UPFRONT COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTING PRACTICES AND COST
DISPARITIES ACROSS DIFFERENT
REGIONS. AB 2734 PROPOSES
SEVERAL AMENDMENTS TO HSP TO
ENSURE ALL FARMERS CAN ACCESS IT
, PROMOTING CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES ACROSS CALIFORNIA. VÀ.
SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL DIRECTS
CDFA TO OFFER GRANTS FOR ON FARM
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS LASTING
UP TO FIVE YEARS, REQUIRES
CONSULTATION WITH ANY RELEVANT
ADVISORY BODIES TO ADDRESS
BARRIERS ORGANIC PRODUCERS FACE
WHEN APPLYING TO THE PROGRAM,
AND REQUIRES CDFA TO AUTHORIZE
HSP GRANT RECIPIENTS TO REQUEST
ADVANCE PAYMENTS OF THE
REMAINING AWARDS FOR INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS MADE PURSUANT TO THE
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE CDFA TO PROVIDE
FUNDS TO TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS TO SUPPORT FARMERS AND
RANCHERS IN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. FOR GRANTS FROM THESE
PROGRAMS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF FUNDED PROJECTS. FINALLY
WOULD PROVIDE GENERAL PLANNING
AND TRAINING FOR CLIMATE SMART
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE. NHÀ
AND LEAD SPERM PURCHASE OR
REPAIR, FARMING, RANCHING AND
FOOD PROCESSING EQUIPMENT THAT
CAN BE CENTRALLY HOUSED WITH THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDER
AND SHARED REGIONALLY WITH
PRODUCERS. THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE. I WILL NOW
PASS IT TO MY WITNESSES. ADDISON
PETERSON, SENIOR POLICY MANAGER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS, THE
BILL'S SPONSOR, AND ANNA LARSON,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK.
THANK YOU, SENATOR MCCONNELL.
THANK YOU. CHAIRWOMAN HURTADO,
VICE CHAIRWOMAN GROVE, AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM
ADDISON PETERSON, SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED ORGANIC FARMERS,
BETTER KNOWN AS COFF. COFF IS A
FARMER LED NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING OVER
3000 ORGANIC FARMS, RANCHES AND
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AB 2734 SEEKS TO
UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE'S
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM, BASED ON
FARMER INPUT, FARMERS HAVE
APPLIED TO THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM FOR NEARLY A DECADE TO
IMPLEMENT CLIMATE SMART
CONSERVATION PRACTICES ON THEIR
FARMS. THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM
IS CRITICAL BECAUSE IT IS
ESSENTIAL FOR REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. WE
APPRECIATE CFA'S LEADERSHIP AND
SPEARHEADING THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM AND MAKING CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENTS. IT IS WHAT IT'S
NEEDED TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND ALSO BE EFFECTIVE FOR OUR
FARMERS. HEALTHY SOILS HELPS
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BY SEQUESTERING CARBON DIOXIDE
FROM THE AIR IN THE SOIL AND
RETAINING MORE WATER IN THE
SOIL, WHICH HELPS TO REDUCE
FLOODING. THE PROPOSED CHANGES
IN AB 2734 ARE DESIGNED TO
ENHANCE THE PARTICIPATION OF
SMALL SCALE AND ORGANIC
PRODUCERS, A MOVE THAT WILL NOT
ONLY BENEFIT THESE PRODUCERS BUT
ALSO CONTRIBUTE TO THE OVERALL
SUCCESS OF THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM. THIS BILL WILL ALSO
DIRECT CDFA TO OFFER GRANTS FOR
ON FARM DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS
LASTING UP TO FIVE YEARS, ALLOW
FARMERS TO REQUEST HIGHER
ADVANCE PAYMENTS, WHICH WILL
MAKE IT EASIER FOR FARMERS TO
PURCHASE NEEDED MATERIALS UP
FRONT. THE ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING
ACT SCIENCE ADVISORY PANEL MAY
CONSULT RELEVANT ADVISORY BODIES
TO ADDRESS BARRIERS ORGANIC
PRODUCERS FACE WHEN APPLYING TO
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM.
AMENDS THE CDFA CLIMATE SMART
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS
PROGRAM TO INCLUDE EQUIPMENT
SHARING AS AN ALLOWABLE COST FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS OR
EXPANDED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
FARMERS, INCLUDING TRAINING,
CONSERVATION, AGRICULTURE,
PLANNING, AND GRANT WRITING.
CDFA HAS ESTIMATED THAT THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM HAS
CONTRIBUTED CONTRIBUTED TO
MOVING OVER 350,000 METRIC TONS
OF CARBON DIOXIDE FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
INCREASING THE PROGRAM'S
PARTICIPATION IN REMOVING MORE
CARBON DIOXIDE FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING. I'M
ANNA LARSON, ASSOCIATE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH CAL AND THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AGRICULTURE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK. AND AS I
SHARED, WE'RE A COALITION OF
EIGHT SUSTAINABLE AND ORGANIC
FARMING ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SUPPORT FARMERS IN BECOMING MORE
RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE. AND
SO, AS ADDISON AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CONNOLLY SHARED, THE
HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM IS HAS
BEEN AN IMPORTANT AND EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM TO HELP FARMERS ADOPT
NEW PRACTICES TO INCREASE THEIR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE AND SEQUESTER
CARBON. AND SO THE PROPOSED
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN SHARED
REFLECT FEEDBACK WE'VE HEARD
FROM FARMERS, TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS AND
RESEARCHERS TO HELP ENSURE THAT
THE PROGRAM IS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
TYPES OF FARMERS. AND AS
MENTIONED, SOME OF THESE CHANGES
INCLUDE EXTENDING THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS TO FIVE
YEARS, WHICH WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
LONGER TERM ON FARM RESEARCH TO
UNDERSTAND THE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND GREENHOUSE GAS IMPACTS OF
THESE PRACTICES, AND THEN
ALLOWING FARMERS TO REQUEST
HIGHER ADVANCE PAYMENTS WILL
MAKE IT EASIER TO ACCESS NEEDED
MATERIALS UP FRONT, AS ADDISON
SHARED, AND THEN PROVIDING MORE
FLEXIBILITY AROUND THE TO FUNDS
WILL ENABLE TÊ PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE MORE WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
AND ALSO HELP SUPPORT THE
CAPACITY OF TO PROVIDERS TO
CONTINUE DELIVERING THIS REALLY
ESSENTIAL AND HIGH QUALITY
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE, AND I JUST
WANTED TO UNDERSCORE, WE KNOW
THAT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CAN BE
REALLY CRITICAL FOR PROJECT
SUCCESS, ESPECIALLY IF FARMERS
ARE TRYING OUT SOMETHING NEW,
AND THIS WAS ALSO UNDERSCORED BY
A PRELIMINARY CAL POLY
EVALUATION OF THE HEALTHY SOILS
PROGRAM, WHICH FOUND THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE GRANTEES WHO
UTILIZE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOUND IT TO BE EITHER IMPORTANT
OR EXTREMELY IMPORTANT FOR THE
SUCCESS OF THEIR PROJECT. YEAH.
SO THANK YOU. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL,
INDIVIDUALS HERE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? PLEASE
COME UP, STATE YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. ABBY ALVAREZ WITH
THE PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ERICA PARKER WITH CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. PAT
MORAN WITH AARON READING
ASSOCIATES, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS, UAW,
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JALEN
JOYCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA,
CALIFORNIA FOOD AND FARMING
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JUSTIN BOWERS, CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS .ORG STRONGLY SUPPORTS. IN
ADDITION NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE FACTS CALIFORNIA NURSES
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY
PIECE. THE NCCA FOR SONOMA SAS
SAFE AG SAFE SCHOOLS MOMS
ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY FOR
THE CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH, NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES AND
YARD SMART MORAN ALSO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. REBECCA
MARCUS, ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
FARMLAND TRUST AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL,
INDIVIDUALS, WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE ON IN
THIS ROOM, SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. YEAH,
WE HAVE A MOTION. OKAY. AND I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR.
JUST WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES. THANK YOU. REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN I
VOTE. THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR STEVE PADILLA
ON THIS MEASURE, ASSISTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE. ITEM
FIVE AB 2734 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNOLLY. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. A SENATOR
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. GROVE
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE.
PADILLA. PADILLA AYE. OKAY. WE
WILL PLACE THAT MEASURE ON CALL.
TO ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. THANK YOU.
OKAY WE HAVE ONE BILL LEFT AND
WE WILL WAIT FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA TO COME IN AND PRESENT ON
AB 20 509. I THINK THIS IS ALSO
A GOOD OPPORTUNITY. MAYBE
THROUGH, TAKE UP CALL AND TAKE
UP ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL AND,
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
NOW HERE AND, AND CAN VOTE ON.
SO ASSISTANT, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL, CAN YOU PLEASE GO THROUGH
THE ROLL FILE ITEM ONE AB 660,
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE CURRENT VOTE
IS THREE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE, SENATORS ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. AYE. SO IT'S OUT.
THE VOTE IS FIVE ZERO, AND THAT
BILL IS OUT, SO WE HAVE A FILE
ITEM TWO AB 1042, THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED, TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATOR
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE.
THAT MEASURE WILL BE ON CALL.
THE MOTION IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO, WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE AND THE VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. SENATORS ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE. WHICH ONE
WAS THIS? THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OH, SORRY. YES. SO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS A VOTE OF 5 TO 0.
AND ALL THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT. AND
THEN, THIS ONE 2313, FILE ITEM
SIX AB 2313 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT, THE MOTION IS DUE PASS
TO APPROPRIATE CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE, SENATOR ALVARADO GIL. I'M
SORRY I MISSED THE ITEM NUMBER.
OH, IT'S ITEM NUMBER SIX. AB
2015. ALVARADO. GIL. AYE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE. FILLS OUT
FOUR ZERO. OKAY SO THAT BILL HAS
FOUR VOTES AND THAT BILL IS OUT.
SING ONE. OKAY, I THINK THAT.
OKAY AT THIS MOMENT, WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE A BRIEF RECESS,
TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLORADO TO COME
IN AND PRESENT HIS BILL. THANK
YOU. DO WE KNOW IF GROVE IS
COMING BACK? OKAY A FIRE GOING
ON RIGHT NOW. SO, YEAH. WHAT'S
THE LATEST, STILL, NOT
CONTAINED, BUT WE'VE GOT SOME.
THE WHOLE TOWN IS EVACUATED, SO.
YEAH. YEAH, IT'S LIKE A LOT OF,
HORSE RANCHES THAT PEOPLE ARE
JUST LETTING THEIR HORSES GO. SO
.
OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE WILL IS BACK TO
ORDER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CARRO,
WELCOME, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS FOR YOUR PATIENCE, 80
2509 CODIFY, CODIFY OR CODIFY?
CODIFY WOULD CODIFY DEFINITIONS
OF INTEGRATED INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT AND INVASIVE SPECIES
AND REQUIRE THE INVASIVE SPECIES
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA TO
PRIORITIZE PRINCIPLES OF
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT IN
ALL OF ITS ACTIVITIES.
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT, ALSO
KNOWN AS IPM, IS A PEST
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY THAT SEEKS
TO MAXIMIZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
PEST MANAGEMENT REMEDIES WHILE
MINIMIZING HARM TO PEOPLE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. IT ACCOMPLISHES
THIS BY MOVING AWAY FROM
TRADITIONAL CHEMICAL ONLY
TREATMENTS IN FAVOR OF NUANCED
SOLUTIONS THAT UTILIZE VARIOUS
PEST MANAGEMENT METHODS,
INCLUDING NON CHEMICAL,
BIOLOGICAL, PHYSICAL AND
CULTURAL TECHNIQUES. IPM STATUS
IS AN EFFECTIVE, ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY APPROACH TO PEST
MANAGEMENT HAS CAUSED IT TO
BECOME AN INCREASINGLY POPULAR
SUBJECT OF LEGISLATION UNDER.
FORTUNATELY, THERE IS NO
CODIFIED DEFINITION OF IPM,
LEAVING EACH PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO CREATE ITS OWN.
THIS CAN LEAD TO CONFUSION,
DELAYS IN IMPLEMENTATION, AND
CONFLICTING ENFORCEMENT ACTION.
AB 2509 ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
CODIFYING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IPM PROGRAM'S
DEFINITION OF IPM. NUMEROUS
STAKEHOLDERS CAME TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT THIS DEFINITION
BALANCES IMPORTANT HUMAN HEALTH,
ENVIRONMENTAL, HUMAN HEALTH,
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION. I LOST
MY SPOT HERE. OH, AND PEST
MANAGEMENT NEEDS. I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH CDFA TO ENSURE
THAT THIS BILL IS COMPATIBLE
WITH EXISTING INVASIVE SPECIES,
EARLY DETECTION PRACTICES, AND
THE GREATER FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL CODE. WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY,
OUR DOUG JOHNSON, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL, AND
ABIGAIL SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF
THE MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
AM DOUG JOHNSON, THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL. WE'RE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO PROTECTING THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY FROM
INVASIVE PLANTS AND THE
COMMUNITY WE SERVE IS THE
COMMUNITY OF LAND STEWARDS, BOTH
PROFESSIONAL AND VOLUNTEER
ACROSS THE STATE, WORKING IN
EVERYTHING FROM NATIONAL PARKS
AND NATIONAL FORESTS ON DOWN TO
LOCAL PARKS AND CONSERVANCIES
AND EVEN VOLUNTEERING IN ONE'S
LOCAL WATERSHED, WE SPONSORED
THIS BILL TO, AS WAS MENTIONED,
DEFINE IN LAW TWO TERMS THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO THE WORK THAT OUR
COMMUNITY DOES INVASIVE SPECIES
AND INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
FIRST ON INVASIVE SPECIES.
THEY'RE RECOGNIZED AS A GLOBAL
ISSUE. AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
NUMEROUS PLANS DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING THEM
FROM THE NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS CONSERVATION, SORRY,
CLIMATE SMART STRATEGY TO THE
STATE WILDLIFE ACTION PLAN,
HAVING A DEFINITION IN CODE WILL
PROVIDE A STRONG FOUNDATION FOR
THIS WORK, THE BILL BASES THE
DEFINITION OF INVASIVE SPECIES
ON LANGUAGE THAT IS ALREADY,
MENTIONED IN STATUTE IN THE
2018, LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADDED TO
ESTABLISH THE INVASIVE SPECIES
COUNCIL, THE STATE'S INTERAGENCY
INVASIVE SPECIES COUNCIL. THE
PROPOSED DEFINITION ALIGNS WITH
THE FEDERAL DEFINITION. THE
SECOND TERM, INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT, IS THE APPROACH THAT
IS TAKEN, THE CURRENT MODERN
APPROACH THAT IS TAKEN TO
MANAGING INVASIVE SPECIES AND
DEFINING IPM WILL AVOID
CONFUSION FROM HAVING DIFFERENT
DEFINITIONS AND DIFFERENT PLACES
IN STATUTE, THE DEFINITION
PROPOSED IS, CONCURRENT WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
DEFINITION, AND IT'S WIDELY
ACCEPTED, AND HAS BEEN FOR
DECADES BY A RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS AND THE STAKEHOLDER
REPRESENTATIVES SERVING ON THE
STATE SUSTAINABLE PEST
MANAGEMENT WORKING GROUP, USED
THIS DEFINITION OF IPM. IPM
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PRIORITIZES PREVENTION, WHICH
MEANS YOU NEED TO KNOW HOW A
PARTICULAR ORGANISM, ITS
BIOLOGY, THE PATHWAYS FOR ITS
POTENTIAL INTRODUCTION, AND WAYS
TO STOP THAT. BUT IF IT'S
ALREADY HERE, IPM MEANS THAT YOU
LOOK TO MANAGE IT IN THE SAFEST
AND MOST EFFECTIVE WAY.
PRIORITIZING NON-CHEMICAL
METHODS, ARE FOR FOLKS WORKING
ON INVASIVE PLANTS ACROSS THE
STATE. YOU KNOW, CUT THEM DOWN,
DIG THEM UP, MOW, GRAZE, BURN,
MULCH, TARP, A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS. AND IN THE PARTICULAR
SITUATIONS WHERE THAT ALONE IS
NOT ENOUGH, THEN HERBICIDES MAY
BE INTEGRATED AS PART OF THE
APPROACH, THE ORGANIZATIONS WE
WORK WITH ARE CHARGED WITH
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY ON THE
STATE'S LANDS, INCLUDING
THREATENED AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES. THEY'RE ALSO PROVIDING
PUBLIC ACCESS, AND THEY'RE
PROTECTING COMMUNITIES FROM
WILDFIRE AND FLOODS. THEY'RE
DEVOTED TO FINDING THE SAFEST
AND MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO
CONTROL INVASIVE PLANTS, AND THE
DEFINITIONS IN THIS BILL HELP
PROVIDE THE FOUNDATION FOR DOING
THAT, SO FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ABIGAIL
SCHMIDT, ON BEHALF OF THE
MIDPENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT. MIDPEN OWNS AND
MANAGES OVER 70,000 ACRES OF
LANDS IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FOR RECREATION AND
PROTECTION OF NATURAL RESOURCES
IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
STEWARDING LANDS, IS WORKING TO
CONTROL INVASIVE PLANT SPECIES
SPECIES SUCH AS FRENCH BROOM,
SLENDER FALSE BROOM AND YELLOW
STAR THISTLE. IN 2014, MIDPEN
BOARD OF DIRECTORS ADOPTED AN
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WITH THE GOALS OF
MANAGING PESTS THROUGH
CONSISTENT IMPLEMENTATION OF IPM
PRINCIPLES, PROTECTING AND
RESTORING THE NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT, AND PROVIDING FOR
HUMAN SAFETY AND ENJOYMENT WHILE
VISITING AND WORKING ON MIDPEN
LANDS, MIDPEN IS FIRMLY
DEDICATED TO MINIMIZING
PESTICIDE USE AND RISK. OUR IPM
PROGRAM FOCUSES ON THE
MANAGEMENT OF INVASIVE PLANTS
AND PROTECTION OF NATIVE
BIODIVERSITY THROUGH THE
PREFERENTIAL USE OF NON-CHEMICAL
METHODS. WHENEVER POSSIBLE,
WHILE RESERVING THE ABILITY TO
USE CHEMICAL METHODS ONLY WHEN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. AB 2509
ESTABLISHES A FIRM FOUNDATION
FOR ONGOING WORK TO PROTECT THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY
FROM INVASIVE SPECIES BY
PROVIDING CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
INVASIVE SPECIES AND IPM.
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVES AROUND
PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCE, INCLUDING 30
BY 30 AND THE OTHER INITIATIVES.
THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY
MENTIONED, ALL STRESSED THE
CRITICAL NEED TO ADDRESS
INVASIVE SPECIES, AND THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HELP TO CREATE
A FIRM STATUTORY FOUNDATION FOR
FUTURE GUIDELINES, DIRECTIVES
AND INITIATIVES TO FULFILL THESE
GOALS. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN FURTHERING ESTABLISHING THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADDRESSING
INVASIVE SPECIES IN CALIFORNIA,
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CLARITY AND COMMITMENT TO IPM
THAT AB 2509 OUTLINES. THANK YOU
. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL, MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME
AND STATE THEIR POSITION ON THIS
MEASURE? CHAIR AND MEMBERS. PAT
BROWN WITH AARON REGAN
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS, UAW IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
JUSTIN BOWERS, CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS. ORG WELL, WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL. IN ADDITION, NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE FACTS
CALIFORNIA NURSES FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
JUSTICE, ECO SUSTAINABILITY,
PEACE AND CA SONOMA SAS SAFE AG
SAFE SCHOOLS MOMS ADVOCATING
SUSTAINABILITY. CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. BEYOND
PESTICIDES, NONTOXIC COMMUNITIES
AND YARD SMART. MARIN ALSO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR CLARIFYING THAT
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE AT THIS POINT. WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND, SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR STATE
THEIR POSITION. WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION. ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. OKAY. WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. SO AT
THIS POINT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ASK OUR COMMITTEE ASSISTANT TO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I'M SO
SORRY ABOUT THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. GO AHEAD. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S WORK
ON THIS. AND THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR, FOR YOUR RECOMMENDATION
AND FOR THE MOVING THE MOVING OF
THE BILL. I APPRECIATE AND I
VOTE ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL FILE. ITEM SEVEN AB 2509 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COLLURA. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER. SENATORS
HURTADO HURTADO AYE GROVE.
ALVARADO, GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. CORTEZ CORTEZ AYE. PADILLA.
PADILLA. AYE POR UN CALL. OKAY.
THAT BILL IS PLACED ON CALL TO
ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE GO ON? SORRY I
WAS JUST. GREAT. THANK YOU.
SHE'S NOT COMING BACK. OKAY
LET'S IT OUT. IF WE'VE GOT.
OKAY. AT THIS MOMENT, WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
CLOSE THE ROLL. SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO. DO WE JUST ANNOUNCE THAT
OATS? YEAH, WE'LL GO AHEAD. THE
FIBER IS ALREADY. GET OUT. TO
ITS THREE ZERO. I'LL JUST GO
THROUGH THE REMAINDER ONES.
WE'LL JUST GO AHEAD AND GO
THROUGH THE REMAINDER ONES THAT
ARE STILL ON CALL. SO ASSISTANT,
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
THE REMAINDER? ITEMS. AND TO
CLOSE TO CLOSE THESE ITEMS WE
HAVE FILE ITEM TWO AB 1042. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY, THREE
VOTES IN FAVOR AND NO, NO VOTES.
THE BILL HAS, THREE VOTES, AND
THAT MEASURE IS OUT. AND THEN
FILE ITEM FIVE AB 2734 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY. Dð.
PASS. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSES TO
APPROPRIATIONS, THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO. AND THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
THAT WRAPS UP OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TODAY. WE'LL SEE YOU
AT THE NEXT ONE. THANK YOU.
EVERYBODY.